one thing i've always wondered is so
we've talked quite a bit on the podcast
about how you know the reach we have has
definitely like affected our lives uh
like off of youtube and especially at
conventions and stuff like that
like us three put together is like a
fraction of the reach that you have like
how has it affected your life like i'm
sorry
i'm genuinely curious about what like
your lifestyle is like and how you've
had to adapt because
it was a little weird in the beginning
because like when you meet fans for the
first time in real life it's kind of
scary and it's like oh and i lived in
like a small town and i was like oh
they're going to find out where i live
they eventually did right right people
show up at my door like three times a
week
seriously
what would they ask for just like to
come in for yeah there was like there
was one time that i always remember
because i lived in like a gated
apartment area right and they got in at
like 9 am i was like how the [ __ ] did
that happen it turns out my neighbors
left them in
because they said oh i was and they were
like he loves meeting people
i don't know you and it was like it was
like a polish family like a mother and
her two kids and they had this big
wooden board with like youtube written
on it and my name is
i wanted to give this to you and i was
like standing there in like my underwear
having just rolled out of bed
on the american accent and just been
like no no this is mark replied
i don't speak english
you should have hit them with the korean
but it got really scary at that point
and then we we moved to brighton and
then i was like militant about not
having my address anywhere and yeah
trying so hard to like keep things
secret and i think that that kind of
messed me up for a long time like even
when i would stream i was so paranoid
that i would like show amazon or
something and it would have like post
coding yeah yeah yeah i've been very
terrified of that too yeah or anything
would just show up on my desktop that
like gave a hint to where i am or what
it was like even like the time on my
clock so i got really paranoid right
right right um but that was also like
fan fervor and they were all like really
big into like shipping and really like
oh fanatical about everything yeah that
era of yuju
which is swinging back now with all the
money afterwards yeah i mean it's uh
still it's it's coming back
definitely coming yeah
thankfully my audience have just kind of
like matured with me and kind of settled
down and yeah i think i think the main
thing that i got out of it was that i
didn't set boundaries early enough right
right and i think a lot of people are
scared of setting those boundaries
because it's like
it makes their audi they think their
audience are going to hate them for
doing that yeah yeah like oh you don't
want us as close you keep saying you
love us and yeah you actually hate us
and you don't want us to come to your
house yeah
[Laughter]
no i don't i skipped about seven steps
there yeah it was like trying not to
rock the boat at all try not to piss
people off yeah because i remember like
i guess we like
people like us have to be thankful to
like the experiences that you went
through because back then it did very
much feel like the boundary just didn't
exist and if youtubers talked about it
then the consensus was well why are you
complaining about this this is this is
they made you they made you why why
aren't you grateful that fans love you
so much you know
i remember that during the whole like
team 10 house remember that oh so many
videos cause we could put the address in
[ __ ] public yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's like a listed google place yep
yeah and then they would turn up and
they'd be like no [ __ ] off and then
there's just so many videos of parents
being like we made you do you know you
wouldn't be this without us
you literally wouldn't be in this
location without me yeah exactly exactly
i mean thankfully it does seem like the
you know the mentality because of so
many bad uh interactions and bad fan
stories that you know people are kind of
getting the point now so you know
thankfully so yeah yeah did you ever
have to look into your security or
anything like that did they ever get to
that point no because everyone was just
so nice about it no one was like doing
any nefarious [ __ ] right right it was
like you didn't have the super weirdos
coming up yeah i say that but somebody
did mail a tub of [ __ ]
to
like a company address that i was
registered at what
um
apparently there's a website that you
can mail
like
different types of [ __ ] to people
so what it showed up
that's very funny what had shown up at
my house was horse [ __ ] but you could
get pig [ __ ] cow [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
and that was like when i was like oh
those are [ __ ] weird was it was it
labeled as horseshit i think sorry
it was like a tupperware kind of thing
like here is your tub of horseshit sir
yeah but it didn't come directly to my
house i went to like a business address
yeah right right
here like was like should we throw this
away and i was like so how long did it
take you guys to realize it was
horseshit it was it's like sitting there
and just like something smells
like a taste test
it was probably after my third spoonful
that's horseshit
it was a rather bizarre phone call to
receive
jack we have a box of [ __ ] did you order
this because somebody sent a cake to me
before right and i was like okay i'm not
eating that yeah of course
actually i did eat it that was stupid
i was like i've done that as well that
was like 2015. we didn't know yeah
that's how we learned the taste of
[ __ ]
yeah
that was the same story just you know
yeah
that was at the point like those were
almost like back to back where i was
like yeah right i was kind of weird that
you're sending stuff to me instead of
like showing up at the house yeah
yeah i think i've seen enough of like
those kinds of videos and like heard
enough of those kinds of stories to know
like because you know during that time
when you're starting off right like
people are like oh so like when are you
going to get a p.o box yeah like send
stuff and hearing stories like that from
early on yeah
never never
no no i yeah i had one it got really
crazy i just imagine it got overrun so
fast yeah you kind of just think like
where am i gonna put all this yeah yeah
and uh yeah well that happened at
conventions i would go to conventions
and people just send us like boxes of
stuff or bring them up to the meet and
greets right it's like i i like paid
like hundreds of dollars to ship it back
to my house yeah yeah yeah it was like
these are so many items it was like
three three or four boxes worth of stuff
yeah yeah want to do with all of this
and then you run out of space then you
have to move and it's like i feel awful
having to like do stuff with this and
it's like
you don't want to like tell people that
you have to like throw some stuff away
which is like awful to think about yeah
i like literally cried one time i was
like having to like put stuff in a bin
and i was like i let everyone down oh
man
and then now i'm like
but that was the thing like no boundary
and now yeah no gifts at these things
anymore because i can't do anything with
you yeah yeah because it's like it's
more of a logistical thing now where you
go you literally can't can't take
everything home and a lot of it
especially like food stuff is it's now
like a health and safety concern maybe
it's got horseshit in it like who
[ __ ] knows
that's something that's something i
didn't think we needed to worry about
until now yeah
i don't want someone out there that's a
fantastic idea people who just met you
guys at the comic-con were like [ __ ]
missed out guys that necklace i gave
them could have been a cold video yeah
exactly
just got to check if anyone's coughing
on that gift before they give it to you
just like detoxifying spray okay yeah
you just lather your cake yeah
like early pandemic when people you saw
those videos people like putting the
hand sanitizer on the apples and stuff
oh yeah what are you doing
fighting covert that's a big
bizarre way yeah not getting covered but
eating hand sanitizer at the same time
yeah have you had like aside from
getting horseshit sent to you have you
had any weird fan interactions just like
at conventions or at events or anything
like that oh yeah because he used to go
to quite a few conventions yeah i think
i think i'm done with them now i think
in 2020 was like right at the start of
the pandemic like right a week after
that was when lockdown happened right
and i got violently ill so i'm
i think i got covered like right at the
beginning right no one was testing that
yeah yeah yeah some people had like
pulled out of vidcon for that
um and after that i was like i risked
dying for a convention and i was like
maybe it's not worth it right and then
i'm like when people go there they don't
really get an interaction with you
anymore because it's like if someone's
there with a timer for like 30 seconds
and it's like a picture shake thank you
bye
it's like i don't want to meet people
that way yeah yeah yeah exactly um
what's what like what's the vidcon
experience like because yeah i don't
have to say like i've only heard the
most like [ __ ] wild things from
people like whether whether it be
positive or negative here wasn't so bad
because i think people here have a
different culture and a different sort
of mindset like europeans are a bit
camera than americans would be
i'm not i'm not stereotyping you [ __ ]
air
i've done a tour in the whole world i
know what you people act like
um
but in in vidcon in la was [ __ ]
batshit crazy it was like the walk in
bed and is it just scary yeah yeah it
was terrifying we weren't allowed out
onto the main hall because you just
weren't they have like a couple of hours
scheduled after one of the days where
creators can go out and experience it
right now wow there's nothing to do
there yeah it's like there's like a
snapchat booth and like i did see it
looked very uh anemic yeah it's working
it's very corporate it's very like
branded and it's very kind of boring for
anyone who's there so people are just
there to see creatives yeah and then
like as that was happening we got to
walk down the main hall and all these
fans like hundreds of them at the window
like faces pressed to it oh my god
yeah it just sounds like
oh god
we went to like the gregory brothers
concert and we went i went the wrong way
because no one was like ushering us a
different world people like literally
like grabbed us and pulled us back out
of the group
and then we're like i went with like
matt and ryan from super mega one year
right and we walked around the back and
we were out like in the apartment area
of it and walking around and some fan
was like i had like a hat i had a mask i
had my hood up and somebody was like oh
i knew it was you from your walk
i was like this is
that's oh my god i've never walked in a
video
i'm like how did you recognize me so
after that i was like maybe don't do
vidcon again right yeah because that's
pretty much the experience we've heard
and that's like it's it's a convention
where
you know as a youtuber you think you
need to go to at least once but every
youtuber i've talked to has been like
you know you don't need to go to vidcon
yeah pax was great though i have so many
fond memories of pax and like right i
want to seem all negative like all my
interactions were bad but yeah people at
pax were absolutely i've had good things
about packs yeah yeah and they would
they'd wait in line for like seven hours
and be starving and just for a chance to
like talk to you and then i was so sweet
and talked about how much you changed
their life and everything
and we were like those would always go
on it was like scheduled for two hours
and they'd go on for like five because
yeah
you just want to actually meet these
people yeah
they're all lovely yeah i mean like
hearing you say that people in europe
and people in the uk are a lot chiller
compared to people in america like
terrifies the [ __ ] out of me because we
just went to a convention last weekend
and uh literally in that one convention
like a random guy just went up on stage
on on our panel and sat next to joey and
that was like to me like i'd never dealt
with anything like that in my life
extremely traumatized
so i'm just like if it's like that in
the uk
uh how is it going to be like in america
so many of them here yeah yeah so it
might be that like it's the first one
we've done yeah yeah yeah literally the
first one we've done so it's now or
never yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
basically like a learning it's been like
a learning experience for us as well did
you go to indie popcorn is that one that
you want to see okay i think i went the
year after you and it was like it was
like this really weird thing where it
was like we do not talk about what
happened
genuinely it'd be like yeah indie pop
got all the stuff like yeah it's been
really good working except for last year
yeah we had markiplier and jack in the
same building and it was like
they said that they were basically i the
message that i heard maybe you can
confirm i just want to know this
personally i don't give a [ __ ]
they basically said that like they were
extremely woefully unprepared is the
message that i heard
yeah we we went i was like 2015 or 2016.
i can't remember yeah and it was the
second convention i ever went to and
it was me mark bob and wade all like in
a line and people
all day just lined up to meet us some
people come back multiple times we
didn't have like a
like a way
to figure it out right people were just
coming endlessly like the first day we
signed for nine hours
we had no food no breaks no anything
then the next day we went again and over
like the three day weekend we did 21
hours of signing did they never cap the
line or anything like that there was no
capping there was no like lottery system
to let people in like everyone was
lovely but it was like we just didn't
know what to do with it yeah yeah nine
hours oh my god yeah i can't even like
fathom that
like just get to the convention sign all
day go to dinner and then do it again
for two more days
it was just it was brutal
yeah cause like i guess was is that like
a common experience with conventions
with you especially in the early days
because i feel like with you being part
of like the early generation of
youtubers where you know you started
seeing the massive reach that you did a
lot of people were just like from what
i've heard just didn't didn't expect you
guys to like have the reach or just have
the fan engagement that you did yeah
yeah yeah because it was at indy popcon
they have a lot of like
like movie stars and like yeah yeah they
they do signings where it's paid for
right right so we were like you don't
want to charge fans to like meet us it's
like yeah i wouldn't pay to meet me yeah
so like we'll just do it for free and
like let people come so it was like
anybody who was anybody was like there
if they wanted to meet someone but
didn't want to pay right some of those
people didn't even know who we were they
were like someone will know right i just
came up to like take pictures and stuff
yeah cause i guess like the even back
then especially back then as well like i
think just the general consensus of like
famous youtubers being at a con was just
like oh yeah you know they just like
make videos online you know how famous
could they possibly be you know compared
to like these like people who have been
in hollywood and tv and stuff like that
yeah and uh little d i guess indie
popcorn no yeah yeah we kept like
sniping people from those lines and then
all the people who had paid signings got
mad at us and were like yeah that's
happening right yeah they're like giving
it away for free like of course no one's
going to come to my booth now and i'm
like i just want to have fun man
some of them do charge like outrageous
prices yeah it was ridiculous like 80
pounds for autograph and it's like what
and you didn't even like really get to
meet them for very long it was like an
autograph and a picture and then buy
yeah yeah don't pay for that
anyone's worth that
you're better than that yeah because i i
feel like i i don't know how it would be
in japan but i feel like there's very
much like
a culture in japan where you you might
very much like pay for something to get
to see this celebrity or this idol
definitely like idol culture right the
uh the illustrious handshake events
sorry yeah idols yeah yeah i saw the
weirdest thing actually now that you say
that in japan where
i
we were like next to a theater um it
wasn't like i don't think it was like a
kabuki theater or whatever it was
there's like a term for it and i can't
remember what it is
um like a traditional theater type of
thing it was like
god i'm trying to like find the words
without seeming offensive
it was like
it's fine it's fine yeah i think it was
like a thing where like ladies would
dress up as like guys and like have like
really impressive makeup and everything
um
yeah yeah
yeah and we we were our hotel was like
right next to a takarazuka theater
and there was like dozens of people
lined up outside every evening and
people would come out and just like say
hi and they were all in line they all
like stood up one by one all perfectly
in unison it was like a swim team like
perfectly cool
like swimming
but they were like they were so
respectful and they were like let's not
do anything on our end like piss them
off or they'll never do this again yeah
and they would come out and they would
like wave to everybody down the line all
the way and there was that would happen
for like a couple of hours and then
everyone would like everyone would leave
and then they were like okay we're done
like fan club go home right right fan
culture in japan is like next level yeah
yeah take it to like the limit yeah yeah
or what is a takarazuku theater so
takaras
basically this like very true i don't
know
a whole lot about it myself but
basically it's been around for i think
close to like a century and it's this
like specific type of uh as you said
it's a specific type of like stage
performance thing that has like very
high regard and high like royalty status
basically right of like yeah basically
like really acclaims uh female stage
actresses
dress up basically they kind of cross
play yeah as like males and you know
it's kind of like think of like if i
don't know a traditional shakespearean
play was happening but all of the stage
performers are female yeah so all the
guy characters are female or the female
female a female characters are female
yeah and it's uh yeah it's like kind of
a musical slash stage player kind of
thing um very very popular in japan for
a very specific demographic i feel like
yeah um mostly like you know kind of
like women between ages like 20 to 50 or
like right
um but yeah it was cool though like it's
really cool yeah some of them would
still come out with like some of the
makeup still on it was really impressive
and then we like looked it up like when
we went back to the hotel to figure out
what's going on like the outfits are
insane the choreography is insane yeah a
lot of money goes into it it's yeah like
some of the highest paid like stage
performers i think in the world i
thought
yeah but i i just couldn't get my head
around it i was like trying to figure
out what it was mm-hmm it just looked
like much
like just this guy yeah i'm trying to
figure out that yeah yeah i don't want
to just say it's women dressing up as
guys like obviously there's more to it
yeah
i don't want to think that yeah but from
a surface that's what it looks like
if you don't know you don't know yeah
yeah yeah it's fine yeah i'm just i'm
not a horrible piece of [ __ ] i swear
please don't cancel me
i don't know how many takaras got fans
we have watching this show you know i
feel the demographic is very different
the one person who knows what you're
talking about just raises their hand
yeah it's like um actually i work in
tons of cars i dare you fancy i've
tapped into that niche
you're gonna subscribers are just gonna
go